rank the planets in order from best to
worst let's start with Earth I think
we'd all agree that we're happy
breathing we're happy being alive and
we've got a lovely son that most the
time keeps it as a relatively
comfortable temperature the second
favorite is Mars I love Mars Mars used
to have a liquid ocean uh in about three
billion years ago Earth and Mars were
very very similar after Mars Saturn's my
favorite I mean it's just the most
beautiful planet in the solar system
with the Rings and it's iconic if you
ask a child draw Planet no chances are
it will be Saturn after Saturn I think
Jupiter a stunning planet again a gas
giant uh we're probably going to go to
Neptune poor old Venus used to be really
really nice then let's go to Mercury
um and then all the way back out to the
last planet then um which is Uranus
um yeah I don't think there's much
exciting about Uranus it feels really
bad isn't it to say so but it was kind
of a bit of a bland pale blue planet